and i want to make sure just for anyone
listening something that i have learned
depression
is repression of emotion
it is a manifestation of some form of of
a deep emotion that's not able to be
expressed
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we have not one
but two very special guests today these
are unprecedented we've never had two we
have never had we the first one episode
before but nikki blades has been with us
this whole day of shooting and so she's
in quite a few other episodes go check
those out and our very special guest of
this episode is miss taran southern over
here we also have jess she's our other
regular yeah
just just just it's jess um but taryn i
have known forever like oh god like over
more than now yeah
we're not all don't math anything
yeah zero now we were like five would be
two plus two equals one yes yes
new map look it up don't google it uh
but yeah we've known each other a long
time and i feel like i've seen you
through a lot of different things and
this past couple years because of the
pandemic i feel like a lot happened and
there's every time i catch up with you
i'm like what else happened
and
it is relatable to a lot of people out
there maybe and dramatic yeah yeah
do you remember anyone out there got
trauma they they want to relate to
anyone um want to feel better about
their trauma because holy [ __ ]
so much
has happened i'm happy to be the poster
child for you can do it yes and you can
do it i was telling her um
off camera that if if i was watching the
taran movie of the past two years that
i'd be like the writers went a little
far like
the character never catches a break like
what is this show like this is a sad
this is where is the happy part it's a
terrible show yeah i've decided the
title of it is tara and the terrible the
title of the show is after happily ever
oh
things were pretty good before they got
bad
everyone take a break to cry just get it
out
i'm still laughing though right yeah
yeah yeah well that's you gotta do you
know
tears
um but let's just indulge
people on maybe what's happened in the
past few years yeah so i think my crazy
journey began actually before the
pandemic um in may of 2019
actually my life was kind of a fairy
tale at that time i was engaged to be
married to my favorite person in the
world i had a movie that i just directed
um that was premiering at the tribeca
film festival your engagement ring was a
cat shaped one i remember that love cats
um
and
so it sort of felt like a lot of things
that i was hoping for in life we're
moving in the right direction
and then the day that my film premiered
at tribeca i found a lump in my underarm
and it was very odd on the day large it
was on the day it was the morning of
like how
i had been sick i got sick in new york i
think probably the stress
yeah okay it feels a big big deal so
it's like yeah i could see that and i
thought well maybe i just have a swollen
lymph node this is so weird a few days
later while i was still in new york a
friend of mine's boyfriend was a
gynecologist and so i had him look at it
because he knew a lot about women's
health he's like that's
i would go get that checked immediately
and so i did and two weeks later i was
diagnosed with stage three breast cancer
right that way already metastasized to
my lymph nodes and i had a
2.5 centimeter by
two centimeter tumor as well as other
tumors that were present in my lymph
nodes i didn't know it was that advanced
by the time you found it oh my gosh yep
and
uh two weeks after that i started
chemotherapy and my entire two weeks
it was like within a month
within a month of finding it i was
starting treatment
um and that that was a
that began a year of
of just insanity in your life that's
what's called the inciting incident in
the right when the writers were like
okay she finds a love at the movie
premiere oh my god
because it's a big deal okay and
everyone thinks like oh my god we're
celebrating yeah let's jump right in
there honestly the best part really good
movie star like
i really want to watch this movie i'm
just like whoa what's next well and what
was sort of sort of strange was my film
was actually following three
patients um all of whom were had
impaired function for different one had
paralysis one was blind and one had
parkinson's so i had spent two years
before that filming in hospitals wow and
watching them
go through this terrible
process of trying to find themselves um
in the midst of hardship and all of a
sudden i was the patient
and it felt like this bizarre
like life imitates art imitates life
imitating alice through looking glass
like you just fell in the rabbit hole
yeah and so that happened and then i
won't even go into the details but went
through uh you know a breakup with my
then partner while i was in treatment
and that was
its own
version of harrowing
i don't know anything about it but the
the man hater that lives like somewhere
deep inside of me wants to think i saw a
statistic somewhere where women will
stick by their men through anything but
the men always want to [ __ ] off when the
girl gets sick i won't start
i don't even know your story like you
don't know the story and you just
[Applause]
obligation
a smelly fetch man i recognize that
smell
and
and that was i mean
you know moving out of my home on
thanksgiving of 2019
right three weeks three months audience
catch up geez
[ __ ] she's thanksgiving and you're
moving out of your arms even like
nothing before the day after
notification were you given a notice
about him
about a month and a half before so
thanksgiving was the day though
thanksgiving was the day that i moved
out and the writers know she's going to
go to home to family and stuff and we'll
get some cool so cinematic strangely
watching it was very cinematic my best
friend was like helping me lug boxes out
of my place it was pouring rain in los
angeles
tornado came through after that
um and
and and then and then yeah i moved into
my own place and i started radiation
gosh i don't i mean i was still healing
from surgery at that point in time and i
think
figuring out what we were going to do in
terms of radiation i think i think i
started radiation a few weeks after that
and i ended up doing six weeks of daily
radiation so i was stuck in la over
christmas by myself
in my little home with my cat
it was fair and the situation that you
had two months maybe three months before
you never would have expected you to be
sitting there i was living my very best
life yeah six months so the drop of a
hat it just everything changed it felt
like everything had been ripped from me
and then
this is where things get real fun
uh so a month later
so we're now in february i believe
february 2020 so a year ago this is a
month before kovit
i'm doing my best to rebuild my life i'm
still in treatment i'm still i've still
got a port in my chest and i'm getting
infusions every few weeks i had a very
um aggressive form of breast cancer so
they
like they're already so advanced that
the tumor isn't yeah and they're worried
that once it's in your lymph nodes it's
in your blood so they don't they want to
make sure that they get every little
cell that could be floating around even
after surgery so
um so i was still in treatment and i go
on a meditation retreat thinking like
this will be a really great way for me
to yeah just really cleanse
start over start fresh clean slate it
clean plate it and i get a call from my
best friend julia who was staying at my
house to look after my cat and she'd
come home and was screaming and crying
because my home had been burglarized
someone had broken into the kitchen
window smashed everything taken
everything my laptop
my engagement ring which i was no longer
wearing
everything of value had been stolen so
really everything's been stripped from
you at this point like just physically
mentally emotionally
what else can we take yep um and then
covet hit
that's just like i can't even
i can't even
like it's right it's too intense absorb
how much that is at one time
the writers just yeah it's like it's
like if you were right if you were
watching this movie you're just turning
the channel you're like i'm watching
this movie i'm turning the channel
because i'm like i can't handle choose
one life-threatening disease or a world
pandemic like or like a burglary like
just choose one
but this is the type of story that if
this is all happening now i'm wanting to
watch
to see how she gets out of it exactly
yeah what's next pandemic comes yeah
yeah how was that process surely friends
start looking up
i mean you know what was interesting i
think um when i was going through all of
it like when i was in treatment when
when
i was going through the breakup
i was almost in some bizarre survival
mode i mean where you're just you
actually are in some state of shock of
course and you can't
process everything that's going on you
start do you stop feeling or stop being
shocked by things or like are you kind
of numb to a little bit like i was
what's next whatever yeah yeah and i had
a i had a 50
chance of having to continue on
chemotherapy for an additional year
which
chemotherapy was
a nightmare for me
um and i was had a very aggressive form
of chemo um can you explain a little bit
why because i think when people hear
chemo at least when i hear it it's like
i don't really i know what it is like
it's a radiation therapy but i don't
really
understand like it's actually different
from radiation oh and i still had to do
radiation too oh um
chemo is a an infusion it's a cocktail
of poisons that uh that you're given to
target the cancer cells and so everyone
who receives chemo receives different
chemo depending on their cancer type
what organ it's in
um and so depending on the cancer types
some chemotherapy drugs you can actually
are livable like you can still function
you can go to work some of them aren't
that bad
but it just depends on
the science and what you had i had a
form of breast cancer called
her2-positive breast cancer which my
aunt passed away from 20 years ago
and 15 years ago if you had her to
positive breast cancer it was a death
sentence
wow
and the new drugs that they have are
amazing but they're
they're rough yeah they are rough so i
had four and a half months of that and i
felt stripped of my ability to do
anything yeah um it was like my you know
you have this port that's implanted in
your chest and they for six hours ingest
these
chemicals in your body
um and my chemo cycle was on a 21 day
cycle
which meant that usually by about day
day three day four i started feeling bad
by day five i was in like a nightmare of
epic proportion and then that would last
for about a week and then you start
slowly slowly feeling better and by day
20 you finally feel like yourself again
and then you go back and do it again oh
my god
um
i was so terrified of having to do a
full year of that like i remember just
saying to my therapist at the time i was
like as long as i don't have to keep
doing that
yeah
so that was when i found out that i
didn't have to keep doing that it was
like
it made everything else livable and
manageable oh my god you're so strong
you're just like one of the most
resilient people i've ever met like i
remember when you were going through
this period and looking at it like
seeing online like your post because you
you posted about this whole process as
you were going through it and i'm just
like she's so [ __ ] strong because she
has a smile on her face the entire time
like you are like explaining what the
process that you're going through you're
able to articulate like everything and
you just are like
this shining like
beam of light like of of like
being able to like help other people
while you're going through it and and
explaining everything and treating it
like a
like a almost like a
like this is what phase i'm of life i'm
in and this is my adventure and i don't
know what's going to happen next but you
were like embracing it and
oh but here seeing that on social media
and then and then hearing you say it in
real life too it's like it just there's
this whole aspect of like
you didn't after i turn off instagram
i'm like oh wow that's a crazy story but
you go and like you're like you're
living
thank you
i need that because there's gonna you
know sniffles oh thank you yeah yeah and
it's painful when you're doing the so
the chemo when you're talking about it
being rough it's like it's painful it
wasn't bad uh going in and they give you
all these steroids and drugs so that you
just don't feel anything it's it's the
days after as it starts attacking the
cells in your body it attacks all the
cells in your body yeah so that's why
you get so sick to your stomach that's
why i mean i the feeling in my stomach
was unlike anything i've ever had before
it was almost like something was like
eating me alive from the inside out and
then um i had terrible terrible nerve
pain so like shooting you know every
nervous system like shooting fireworks
throughout my whole body which made it
impossible to sleep
um it was just very painful and and no
pain drugs helped that either for me um
so it was just
you cannot cope with trauma
when you don't feel well right yeah and
so at least being able to go through
what i went through subsequently
you know i wasn't in chemotherapy like i
was able to
have my mental weights about through a
whole deeper level of pain that going
through the breakup was like a like you
know what fine yeah
yeah i got my i got my bill and and even
then you know you're sort of waiting for
the shoe to drop it's not like any any
stage you're like i'm clear there's a
whole joke with cancer patients like
you're good until your next scan
and the first two years are actually the
scariest because
you do surgery but once it's in the
bloodstream right you don't really know
so the first two years are really
important and i just got my second year
clear scan this week
so it's like such a big deal thank you
writers thank you very much
okay
we might get a second season okay good
good yeah
but um you know you're just you're
always like waiting for the shoe to drop
but i will say like being able to be
healthy through that was really
important it wasn't until
a year
after
even a little bit more a year after i
had started treatment so really summer
of last year
was when i started having ptsd
yeah like really bad ptsd and i um
i lost a friend of mine who had also
been going through treatment at that
same time
um she was diagnosed a week after me i i
think
and you're hearing
like your close friend did she have the
same thing or she did she have a
different type of cancer um she also had
breast cancer but a different type yeah
um and we had
sort of become you know
friends while we were going through
treatment together and so i you know i
just never anticipated that that's how
things were going to end for her and i
think that that also triggered i think a
trauma response around just how serious
this was right
and
um and so last fall i spent a lot of
last fall in
serious therapy like processing i ended
up going to bali for two months
in the middle of the pandemic i i
figured out how to get to boston i was
like i was like
good for her i did an eat pray love
except it was just yeah mostly just i
think praying yeah
um i met with every shaman every healer
i just i went i i screamed at rivers for
days on end cried my guts out
and until i felt like there were no more
tears left to cry
and
and you know at a certain point like you
do start to to see
like a crack of sunlight again yeah like
you feel like
you can't like cry forever like it's it
empties out at some point and then it's
clear for you to rebuild again
yeah do you feel like you've reached a
point where you
do you feel like you need like there was
a point to this or
or do you think like i don't need that
like i
i mean how do how are you feeling now
about kind of like as is trauma stacking
and you like keep getting hit like more
than most people ever do in their entire
life in such a condensed amount of time
do you feel like you're searching for a
point to that or are you okay that
there's not a point to it or i that's
such a good question and i actually
think that last fall the reason why i
felt so depressed and probably part of
the reason i had a lot of trauma ptsd
coming back up was because i had not yet
found meaning in what i'd gone through
and i saw the death of my friend as
something that felt at that time it felt
pointless and it felt i was angry i was
angry that
that tit that she was gone and yeah i
just couldn't find meaning in any of it
and anyone who told me that there was
meaning in it i'm like
jim like [ __ ] you easy
yeah yeah and i think i had to just feel
it and move through it the senselessness
of all of it to get to a place where
i can
create
you know you can really only create
meaning once you're on the other side
and you create it and it's a story
we all have stories that we tell
ourselves and
i've decided that i'd rather tell myself
like a hopeful optimistic story
than something else so yeah through that
process though
what was your motivation to want to
fight
the ptsd because a lot of people become
victim to it and we have lost so many
people due to it you know suicide is a
very very serious issue that we're
facing and especially during the
pandemic how are you able to find
something to want to fight for
well i mean i think for one i i was like
well i'm still here
like i'm still here yeah and
that felt like enough
and then i also just feel like i have
the most loving incredible friends and
community
who are who just
fought for me when i didn't have it in
me right to fight and held me like
literally holding me while i stop on the
ground yeah um and and quite honestly
like another big part of this for me
i'm a huge advocate of plant medicine
therapy okay and that was a big
component part of this i mean i tried a
lot of different therapies i tried i
started with emdr which is um like a
specialized sort of behavioral
i don't know if you call it a behavioral
therapy it's a specialized therapy that
you can
kind of find any therapist that does it
um i found that very helpful it's very
good for trauma
um
but i also did
you know a handful of healing sessions
with ketamine therapy which is licensed
and available here in los angeles i'm
interested in this side you should get a
little a little deeper into that wow
and we will get deeper into that right
after a small break from our sponsors i
can't tell you how many times i've used
doordash in the last
several months i
literally i don't even go anywhere
anymore same it's every day multiple
times a day i'm on doordash i love
doordash
i love it and the the interface like the
user interface or whatever i love it so
much better than any of the other
delivery choices yeah and it looks
better it's easier to use i just it's
but it's the best app so far
on the market yes doordash connects you
with the restaurants you love right now
and right to your door and now you can
get the grocery essentials you need with
doordash too get drink snacks and other
household items delivered in under an
hour ordering is easy open the doordash
app choose what you want from where you
want and your items will be left safely
outside your door with contact list
delivery drop-off setting with over 300
000 partners in the us puerto rico
canada and australia you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your national favorite restaurants like
popeye's chipotle and cheesecake
today yeah cheesecake factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
mood if you've been using any other app
just stop try doordash for a little bit
stop just i swear just stop and try to
playing around stop 2022. go to the best
app actually uh the reason why i picked
doordash over all the other ones too is
because i've compared the prices too and
like the fees and doordads it's the best
option absolutely that's 25 off up to 10
value zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download doordash app in
the app store and enter code mood don't
forget use our code mood for 25 off your
first order with doordash subject to
change terms apply fanduel sportsbook is
an official sports betting partner of
super bowl 56 and to celebrate new
customers can bet five dollars to win
280 dollars in cash on either team to
win when you use promo code big mood
when registering that's right you'll get
your winnings in cold hard cash because
we know that cash is always better than
quote unquote free bets
there's no better place to bet super
bowl 56 than fanduel sportsbook they've
got tons of promotions for new and
existing customers they've got same game
parlays where you can combine small bets
for bigger wins there's tons of super
bowl props and more honestly now that my
packers are out of the super bowl uh
r.i.p i'm very sad about it i gotta root
for the rams gotta represent la got to
come through for my dad's favorite team
but i am very sad that the packers
aren't in the super bowl however i could
still make money off the game by betting
on fanduel and it's so easy to use don't
miss your chance to turn five dollars
into hundred eighty dollars in cash
download the fanduel sportsbook app and
use promo code big mood to make every
moment more of this super bowl again
promo code big mood exclusively on
fanduel sportsbook disclaimer you must
be 21 and over and present arizona
colorado connecticut iowa illinois
indiana michigan new jersey pennsylvania
tennessee virginia or west virginia new
year's only ten dollars first deposit
required must wager and designated offer
market max bonus 150 bonus for tennessee
users were filled in site credit within
72 hours tennessee site credit expires
14 days after receipt restriction supply
see full terms at sportsbook.com.com
gambling problem call 100 gambler or
visit dot com rg in colorado iowa
michigan new jersey pennsylvania
illinois in virginia one 800 next step
or text next step to 53342 in arizona
888 789 777 or visit ccpg.org chat in
connecticut 1-809 with it in indiana
tennessee redline 1-800-889-9789
in west virginia okay
everybody take a deep breath
before we get back started and you need
it yeah but yeah your strength i know
there's so many people watching right
now whether they've been going through
it or family members or friends of those
that have gone through it i watched one
of my best friends her daughter go
through treatment actually during the
pandemic as well she's about like eight
years old and i remember the effects
that it had on the family and i remember
how much even though we knew it was her
going through it but everyone's strength
throughout the process to be there to
help her so just to hear what you went
through and your fight to make it again
i i go back to that because
some people it's just so hard and they
don't have the support system but to see
you find that purpose and that reasoning
and then looking at those around you and
seeing
that you had people that loved you that
your fight was like you're fighting not
just for yourself but for them as well
so i just want to commend you on that
because that is absolutely beautiful
thank you so much thank you so you
started getting
therapy and um like well you were
talking about plant therapy or plant
medicine yeah um so what it what's ke
i'm sorry what is ketamine therap i've
never heard of it so there's a number of
different
compounds that would count as plant
medicines i actually don't know if we
can count ketamine as a plant medicine
but it is a psychotherapeutic medicine
and it's a psychedelic
um i believe that it is kind of like
micro dosing
nope ketamine is like you want to go to
the moon okay
they use ketamine in veterinary science
right yes it's a horse tranquilizer but
it's also used in surgery centers
for certain people that can't uh be
sedated with certain types of anesthesia
they use ketamine i've only heard of
ketamine in a very
my first experience hearing about
ketamine i was actually a burning man
and someone was like in a stupor
in a like in a in a sand hole and i was
like what's happening over there they're
like that guy's in a cage
and i'm like that looks terrible
but i'm gonna figure it out
okay okay so yes you so you witnessed it
before even trying it yeah how was how
that wasn't in a controlled manner
therapist but still yeah the thought of
it you've seen it
used uh
outside of that environment was not
interested yeah and now it's presented
to you as an option to help you through
what you're going through now how did
you come to that conclusion that you
wanted to go this route with your
therapy with your healing so i had tried
uh previous to this when i've been
through some other bouts of of stuff i
think it's starting in my late 20s was
when i first started getting into
healing plant medicines and so i had
done psilocybin journeys
ayahuasca and i had found
interesting enough results to be
open-minded about it yeah you know of
course while i was going through
chemotherapy and treatment like that you
don't want to put anything in your body
that could
yeah i mean that was like a psychedelic
enough experience
um but as i was starting to emerge and
feeling physically better
and and feeling this trauma come up
again i just had a sense that like
just regular run-of-the-mill therapy
wasn't gonna do it for me the emdr was
helping a lot um but i met with a
ketamine therapist who had come highly
recommended she lives in works in venice
this woman lauren taus she's amazing
and you can have it prescribed for
anxiety and depression so i thought all
right i'll give this a go
and i did it and oh my goodness i mean
i was actually stunned
i was like wow this is pretty this is
pretty intense this is pretty powerful
it was on par with my ayahuasca okay
experience
yeah so did you see visuals oh yes oh
yes you are in but different than
psilocybin or ayahuasca those tend to be
highly geometrical kind of fantastical
um
dark
ketamine was like imagine being an
avatar where everything is in 4k oh and
your brain is creating these beautiful
would be more like mdma vibes kind of
like more happy lovey kind of like soft
or does it depend on yourself mdma
you're not neces you're usually not
having visuals
i suppose some people can softer kind of
just like softer brighter happier kind
of vibe
well it's also a tranquilizer so you're
you're relaxed as you're as you're
experiencing what your brain is creating
for you
and they don't i don't even know if they
necessarily know the mechanism of how it
works or at least if they do i don't i
don't know but it has shown to decrease
symptoms of depression and treatment
resistant depression patients and
anxiety and i think something that
happens which is what happens with other
psychedelics as well and why they are so
powerful is there's this separation that
you suddenly experience from your own
experience
so you know how when you're in trauma
yeah it's this overwhelming
physiological experience that takes over
your body you cannot separate yourself
from that
from
what's happening did you
realize your body was like the avatar
like you started looking at yourself as
like this is your physical form but it's
not like you can zoom out of your body
yeah i know like well you have to tell
sex is what she's trying to say
not that kind of avatar but did
did you have the separation was it
um i think what happened more on
ketamine for me gosh all of these
medicines are so different um
which is fascinating but i think what
ketamine did for me was a
i did feel this like cosmic connection
to everything
yeah that was like un it was
unmistakable and gentle
and m and made me feel like a sense of
it's all okay
it's all okay and all of your pain is so
beautiful and if you can hold that and
it's indescribable because it's what
you're experiencing you're embodying
it's not just a mental thing it's like
it's going to every cell nothing can be
taken from you because you're one with
everything and
you just feel that instead of it being a
cerebral thing of like okay i am one
with everything and yes and this is how
it works it's like a feeling about it
you believed it i totally believed it
and i saw
my disease as
a manifestation of my
dis ease yes with
certain things in my life where i had
not had a voice or not felt i'd had a
voice
and not used that voice and so i started
making these interesting connections
through the experience of how
empowered i could be now that i can feel
in my body the manifestation of
uneasiness and anxiety and what that
does and sort of seeing the cancer is
like a weird gift of that have you ever
read any books by louise hay no but i'm
very familiar with her okay yeah well
for those of you out there there's a
book called heal your
heal your body heal your life or heal
yourself here you'll
heal your life i don't remember but it's
there's two like it's like heal your
body look up louise hay and it is
exactly what you're talking about right
now where it's this um like where your
dis ease and your stress can manifest
into physical form
in parts of your body and she actually
breaks down and i don't know it's been
so long since i've read the book but
that she breaks down like what parts of
your body like let's say there's
something in your neck it's associated
with you you not wanting to change like
it's like different parts of your body
that are
experiencing disease or pain or you're
getting hurt or continuously injured in
the same part of your body it represents
something that you're storing there that
you need to work on like as a whole
person and i just thought that was
always so
interesting and then that reminded me of
that of that that
yeah your body cr if you don't deal with
it like if you don't process your
anxieties emotions your stress it
actually creates a physical illness or
disease in you i think
all a lot of our ailments that we have
are connected in ways that we just have
no understanding of yet in in scientific
medicine that we will because we'll have
the tools eventually but
around how our emotional and cognitive
states impact our body i mean we know
stress is bad right yeah we know that
people die earlier who are under chronic
stress and it can cause like heart blood
pressure it's also one of those things
like yeah we know stress is bad yeah
they can kill us but we don't treat
stress
because
we take a pill yeah
yeah we don't treat it we look at it
everybody has stress right yeah so
that's kind of like a very throwaway you
know like stress you can become sick
because of stress but at the same time
if you tell someone you're stressed
they look at you there's there's a lack
of empathy around stress
until it's too late
until it's like i was so stressed now i
became sick and now you care but yeah we
don't i feel like we're still learning
how to
be empathetic towards us or recognize
the root and like oh let's why don't you
relax today because
you eat it your body needs it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and so developing that
sort of radar and antenna internally and
noticing when things are off i think
it's become a big focus through this
journey this healing journey awesome
that's really cool
you can't really when you're going
through it be like well it was all for
this reason but as you continue along
the path you're like okay i'm connecting
some of the dots like yeah if i hadn't
gone through this part then i wouldn't
have realized
that you can
possibly prevent more things from
happening by eliminating the root that
may be stress and maybe like the anxiety
and all the stuff that i'm not
addressing 100 yeah and as things unfold
you find new meaning in them and
life just
become a very interesting
chapter book
i was going to ask going through
everything you've gone through how do
you view life
if someone was to ask you
describe your
life
right now
how would you describe it in this moment
to some like as simple as possible well
i chose something very dynamic
[Laughter]
high amplitude
um no i mean it's
oh man that's such a great question and
i feel like i don't have a good simple
answer other than
i i do feel incredibly grateful to be
here
and even with all the pain it still
feels worth it
and i do
i do see myself on a mission
to make every day every moment this life
as adventurous as possible and that
means that i might get more
of the bad with the good when you make
choices that are
out there but it feels worth it it feels
worth it
i totally believe we only get one of
them wow and so i'd rather yeah higher
exactly yeah reward i'd rather take as
many risks as possible do you feel the
same way do you feel more
human
going through everything you've
experienced like is this
something that made you feel more
connected not only to the universe but
kind of to other people yeah i don't
think i think i'd lived a pretty good
life up until a couple years ago i don't
think i'd been through a whole lot of
traumatic events and i have so much more
compassion for people that do and i am
so grateful i mean how lucky am i that
even in the midst of everything that i
was going through that i had the time
and the resources to actually be able to
seek out
healing
yeah and like people with kids who don't
have money who are struggling to make
ends meet and who are dealing with
disease ailment i mean the trauma can be
so intense for so many people and
they're not able to take the time right
to actually get the healing that they
need and that breaks my heart because
they still have to be the caretaker even
when they are not being able to take
care of themselves yeah how many people
get to go take two months and go to bali
yeah
wow that's a good perspective to have on
that of all what i'm hearing right now i
feel like you've learned all like you've
got a much more
in-depth more enriched um perspective of
the human experience
is there any like thing that maybe you
would tell even
taran from a few years ago like
about
like what we don't know about the human
experience oh
these are such good questions i feel so
unprepared i think i am still i'm you
don't have to i'm also still a student
like i'm still you know i'm just like
yeah is that you're we haven't gotten to
some of the stuff yet but like
like it's after all this
you're learning so much there's more
then you're thrown back into like okay
let's put you back into like the
everyday
uh like heartbreaking situations
the rest of the species is going through
as well so i take it now that you are
working on yourself you've re-entered
society and the story continues the
story did continue all right so now we
are back
i think part of it's like the universe
just wants to make sure that um things
don't get too good you know yeah
it's like hey remember that [ __ ] that i
told you i give you a powerful lesson
did you learn it did you did you learn
it
did you learn it yeah don't get too
complacent all right but i also i mean
and i will also say this like there's
you know i recently took a new job um
that was a big thank you and that was a
really big
change for me um i'd never had a job job
in my life
like i i'm not it's not like a shocking
thing because i feel like a lot of us
and that's this space have been like
yeah whoa well you have a job job now
that's crazy
yeah it was uh it was a big shift and
because i've liked nikki been doing
entertainment my whole life and kind of
had my own just was running my own shift
yeah doing a lot of different projects
and that level of instability while
going through treatment and coming out
of uh end up in a relationship was
very unsettling and so finally this year
i kind of called it in i was like i
don't know if it's a job or if it's just
a new way of reorienting but i need
something needs to change with the
career
and so i took a job and um i love it and
it's been
it's you know it's been a big shift um
in
my the way i go about life but it's that
has been
can you say what you've been wearing
yeah so i'm a creative director of a
company called blackrock neurotech oh
they're an implantable uh device company
and
they um i first started working with
them through this film that i directed
several years ago where i followed
patients who had implantable brain
computer interfaces yeah i got to see
the movie you did you can people see it
still on yeah you can watch it on amazon
and apple i think okay yeah what's it
called uh i am human i am using wow yeah
it's really fascinating you know what
i'm gonna say tonight very in-depth yeah
about all of the implants yeah implants
yeah and so this company that i'm now
working with they they actually make the
technology and the platform that allows
for
people to move again and see again and
hear again and like these truly
miraculous things that we're able to do
to the human body
uh engaging with the brain and i get to
do sort of everything creative related
to the company and so it's like in a
weird niche it's a world that i happen
to know about yeah and i get to do all
this really cool creative work so um
that's so good and have consistency
that i needed i needed like one
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
that job that jobby job will remind you
because monday through friday you still
gotta come in that job is gonna be there
you gotta be there
and sometimes it's that
constant thing yeah it's like the
structure like you are creative still
but now you have a structure to be
creative because you're like i don't
know how i feel but you've figured out
how to merge
your world that's right and get the
stability that you need during this time
because it sounds like
this was the only stable thing
i'm just i mean i'm just reading the
room
the story i'm picking up the energy from
here and i know she's like and yeah this
sounds great but there was other stuff
that was going on at the time so the
consistency of the job really
the stability of the job yeah kind of
gave you a bit of peace of mind i think
i could put my head on solid ground for
a little bit yeah i mean oh
100
and when you when you have the loss of a
partnership
loss of your health i think loss of a
job moving i mean all of these things
yeah
a pandemic
yeah you know
each one of these things will
force the ground beneath your feet to
falter right so having one thing that
can feel stable yes tremendously helpful
so i totally get that very grateful for
that but yeah i mean i think ultimately
i don't even remember where she would
have this beautiful segway and oh i was
saying now you're back into
like kind of like the uh you're back to
normal problems that are still
heartbreaking but they're like so you
recently went through a couple
breakups like sometimes like normally
our whole life is like oh my god the
breakup that's crazy and like we're
talking about one breakup the whole time
and yeah and this is like now you're
back in to
like a relatable level of problems but
it's still like so heartbreaking because
you're in it right now yeah i fell in
love with someone
and
um
we had this
just really amazing
relationship and connection um
but due to i think a lot of things
outside of
my control
um
and maybe his control too but it just
didn't work out and so i'm i'm i've been
i was telling nicky i was like the last
three weeks the first two i was like
back in the bed
lots of tears a lot of academy yeah
didn't go back to ketamine
only using it when necessary
um but
uh but yeah i'm now like i think i'm
coming out of like i think i'm in week
four um this is still very break up so
it's still fresh yeah it's very sad
but it's also um but i also feel
i'm already getting to the place of
total gratitude
like the fact that i could even fall in
love with someone again yeah
that was i didn't know it was possible
that's after what i've gone through
like without having gone through all the
trauma that you've been through
sometimes i'm like i really don't
believe that i'm gonna fall in love like
and i'm just i'm only 34 i've got so
many years ahead of me but part of me
and my soul is like i just don't think
i'm gonna fall in love again so even
just having it for a short period of
time
is still beautiful yeah yeah and i
carried that exact fear
i was like there's just no way i'll be
able to fall in love in the same way
again and open myself up to that
type of thing
um we're going to take another break but
when we come back
get ready for
after this ad break we're going to get
more heartbreak so
please prepare yourself get the tissues
the most joyous podcast
these days it feels like online shopping
is the only shopping that we really do
come on that's why today's sponsor honey
comes in clutch it's the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
promo codes and automatically applies
the best one available at checkout honey
is basically your online shopping best
friend it seriously saves me so much
money every time i shop online i mean
these little two dollar savings five
dollar savings 15 savings they really
add up over time to where it's honey's
probably saved me hundreds of dollars no
cap here's how it works you get honey on
your computer or iphone for free by
going to joinhoney.com
big mood then when you're shopping on
one of your favorite sites at checkout
the honey button will automatically
appear and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds and
then honey will search any available
coupon for that site and if honey finds
a working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop it also lets you know like if you
already have the best price which i
think is pretty
pretty honest and pretty cool of them to
do but you know for sure that you're
getting the best price at checkout when
you're using honey uh it saved me just a
ton of money on all the websites on
urban outfitters every time i shop for
clothes every time i shop for makeup at
sephora honey is always saving me money
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and supporting the show so get honey for
free at joinhoney.com
big mood that's joinhoney.com
big mood if you sell stuff online you're
definitely in the right business more
people are shopping online than ever
that means a lot of orders coming in and
a lot of orders you'll need to ship out
fast that's why online sellers love
shipstation no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship all your orders from all
your sales channels faster cheaper and
more efficiently no matter where you're
selling whether it be amazon etsy or
your own website shipstation funnels all
your orders into one simple interface
that you can manage from anywhere even
on your cell phone you'll get access to
amazing discounts with major carriers
including ups fedex and usps you can
easily compare carriers and choose the
best solution every time with
shipstation small businesses can now
access the same rates usually reserved
for fortune 500 companies without the
contracts or commitments it's no wonder
shipstation has more 5 star reviews than
any other shipping software ship more in
less time just use our code big mood to
get a 60 day free trial that's two
months for free no hassle stress free
shipping just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in big mood so they
know we sent you that's shipstation.com
enter offer code big mood make ship
happen um so uh
so you're moving on from a heartbreak
but one thing
that you had mentioned off camera too
was um that in a way
like all these things are crazy and
devastating but it all like it made you
much stronger and able to like have the
confidence to know that like yeah this
[ __ ] sucks like i'm going through
something that's heartbreaking it's
devastating it's painful it [ __ ]
sucks and also i know i can get through
it because i i've gone through way worse
than that yes and you almost you feel
the pain coming on and now i've learned
all these techniques like where do i
feel the pain in my body having these
kinds of conversations when you're so
you know you can be on the bathroom
floor or sobbing but to actually say
where do i feel it in my body can i give
it love can i like there's all these
different tools that i've used to help
soften the edges of what's happening and
to kind of move through it um
but i i do feel when i feel things
coming on i'm like i've been here before
and i will i will it will pass yeah it
will pass you know that's kind of where
i'm at again i'm like all right this is
painful and i'm gonna be okay and i have
like just again constantly gratitude
gratitude gratitude like
what are the beautiful things that i can
take away from this that's so awesome
because i think i really do believe in
that um
your mind is really powerful like more
than you get that anyone gives it credit
for and the mind over matter thing and
but not just that but like you really
can shift your physical being from your
thought thoughts become things and and
you if by shifting towards that
gratitude state because everyone goes
like what are you grateful for okay like
everyone's got problems but what are you
grateful for make a gratitude list i
hate that one yeah when you're going
through a depressive episode when you
have depression and they're like well
make a gratitude list like there's so
many people that lose limbs every day
and you look at you with arms um but
like really like actually you know being
open and being like okay i'm really
grateful that i have this and and
embodying that and um
like reminding yourself of that it does
lift something
off of you that makes it less heavy
to carry and get through life i will
also say that because i went through a
depression last fall where gratitude was
very far away yeah and i want to make
sure just for anyone listening something
that i have learned depression
is repression of emotion
it is a manifestation
of some form of of a deep emotion that's
not able to be expressed
and whether that's because your own body
is not allowing you or your mind's not
allowing you because it's in protective
mode whatever that is and it doesn't it
could be unconscious right
um it could be that there's ptsd there's
trauma there's something that's but i
believe this and from a lot of
literature i've read it seems to be true
so whenever i feel like a
depression-like thing coming on i tell
myself that this is the moment that i
gotta go to the scary place
because i have felt that gratitude only
comes
after i'm literally screaming and crying
my heart right yeah and actually moving
things out of my body and creating space
you can't use gratitude to repress to
continue to repress yeah so this the
toxic positivity that people talk about
where it's like put on a happy face
happiness is a choice it's like okay
yeah but you have to feel the real [ __ ]
too
like to process it yeah and and
to be grateful you have to truly feel
grateful it's not something i just say
i'm grateful for yeah when i'm depressed
i'm not
when when depression is hit and there's
been times like again feeling as we had
discussed this um identifying where it
is and what i can do and sometimes you
got to feel the [ __ ] um i want to say
like a couple weeks ago i was glued to
my couch and everything i've ever gone
through decided to visit me that day and
all i knew is that i needed to just sit
there
and breathe through it there was there
was no going to the gym there was no
making a phone call there wasn't anybody
that could help me other than me but to
feel it i felt as though my chest
was pushing to my spine and it was
pushing me into my couch and i couldn't
move
and no matter how grateful and no matter
who loves me i couldn't feel it then
yeah but there's something with muscle
memory and when we've gone through
certain things that our body learns how
to take over so with sports you do the
same thing over and over and over and
over again so that when it comes time to
perform you can do it
so
when you were describing what you had
gone through i was like your body has
muscle memory now you know what to do
when the situation arises so you
understand that this
sucks
but my body and i know
what this feels like and what we need to
do to get past it and so when it happens
again i'm prepared and every day you
practice these things that make you feel
like living is worth it and gratitude is
in you and not just something you're
saying out loud it's like you're taking
that ground ball every day whether you
miss the ball you just know that when
you're in the game and it's really time
when that day that the depression feels
like it's going to win there's something
in you that just says
no we've done this before
we can get past it so sharing that it's
very
very relatable to a lot of people yeah
because
depression doesn't come with one
traumatic event some people
just can feel like silence yeah you know
and you can hear somebody that's
actually gone through so much and people
that do struggle with depression are
struggling with that feeling of guilt
like why don't i feel grateful yeah and
it actually adds on to it because i feel
guilty that i feel sad even though i
can't help feeling sad and i'm not sad
about a thing that's logical it's just
there
and i'm like and now i feel bad for feel
feeling that way
yeah but 100 and as you hear people talk
about their experiences with depression
yeah and how they make it to the other
side it's it's hopeful it gives people
hope yeah because again no matter
whatever you're going through we're all
feeling something and everybody's
experiences are different so finding
that purpose
that
reason
is amazing and you even sharing and i
feel like we still haven't even gotten
into the grit
of what it is to be on the other side of
it because now you've survived so many
things and you are grateful for the
things you survived but life hasn't
stopped yet how do you
look towards the future like what is
something that keeps you so optimistic
outside of knowing that you have like
this purpose is there something
that you feel that just drives you
i actually do feel really excited about
the future
um which is interesting uh
i
i feel driven
by a couple things i think i feel driven
i have just a genuine love for
life
and i think i have
honed in on the people and the things
and the routines that give me even tiny
amounts of joy so like just instituting
a practice
of these various things
just allows me to be more present and
feel joy more frequently also knowing
and accepting that pain is part of that
yeah but i think the excitement for the
future is like
it's kind of funny it's an epiphany
that's come out of all my pain which is
like
never a dull moment like i
really don't know how things are gonna
go
like my life's not boring
no it's really not boring i had one i
had a girlfriend call me a couple months
ago and she was like taryn you really
have chosen the most dramatic movie yeah
you're like welcome to blockbuster your
soul if reincarnation habit like if you
believe in that that you choose your
life before you come back to earth
you chose uh an interesting one i think
what happened was you tripped and then
you like fell off
all of the buttons
you smashed all the buttons
i'm going to the oh yeah yeah
i [ __ ] end up in this goddamn
basement or last tyrion was an
accountant
i was so bored
i was so like this is in my next life
i'm gonna have some drama yeah i want to
play bumper cars with the edges of the
matrix
i do have a question yeah now with this
plant therapy stuff were you at any time
before starting any of that
religious or spiritual in any way and
then after trying the various like
ayahuasca academy that like do you feel
any difference in kind of any tor like
spirituality or a religious type of way
i grew up in a pretty
religious community my parents were
christian are christian
um wichita kansas pretty conservative
right mostly christian
um
so those were the beliefs that i was
raised in i would say by college i had
i had really turned away from a lot of
the the traditional beliefs that i'd
been taught
um and would have identified as an
agnostic through you know all of my
adulthood basically um which by the way
i think makes trauma really hard when
you when your core belief system is that
um everything is sort of random and
nothing really matters and unfortunately
or unfortunately i am
science brained like i i don't totally
even with therapy i'm like tell me why
this works and it's gonna and then it's
it actually for me once you understand
the why
um
and so much of spirituality is not
understanding the how or the why it
works yes yeah also why so many people
reach for it
that's right that's right like save me
for i don't want to do anything you
saved me from my pain yeah so there's
yeah if you get too far in one extreme
of course yeah and so but it was a
slippery slope and i feel like through
my different plant medicine experiences
um i always had a tricky relationship
with the word spirituality because i
associated it with religion right but i
but a hundred percent experienced
magical
mystical moments where that are
inexplicable and seem seem on some level
to give you certain codes to the
universe that you just either cannot
access in regular life or we just don't
have the time and the energy and the
space to access them and so i think i
think in my new version of self uh i
sort of have this belief that science
actually is the language of mysticism
but we're just we just don't have all
the tools yet oh i got so many books for
you yeah i can't wait to share them and
so i have a much more flexible view is
there any spirituality do you feel like
when you i guess i don't know i don't
know if it's appropriate to say you
crossed kind of into like a place where
you got closer to the spirit of the
universe did you feel like it told you
anything that like we should know like
do you have any oh yeah girl i didn't
messages from
what did they tell you yeah yeah well oh
my gosh and it's always so i wish i
should give it more time i should spend
more time like writing because i think
there's so much
power in in distilling down or trying to
translate concepts that you learn while
on plant medicine right um i did
actually did an ayahuasca journey in
january in bali and i hadn't done it for
10 years so i was actually really scared
because ayahuasca i'll just say it
kicked the [ __ ] out of me it was a
difference
it seems very very it was i was like i'm
never doing that again
right and and but i it was weird i felt
it in every cell of my being that it was
time for me to meet mother ayahuasca
again
don't call me again oh my god and
it was i mean i have chills thinking
about it again it was one of the most
beautiful experiences i've ever had i
went in i took the medicine and you go
in and you're like in the vortex of
another reality yeah
and i immediately felt like the inner
voice that was coming it was like
emanating from all my cells and you you
feel as though every cell in your body
is downloading information yeah
yeah and that you're able to actually
see under underneath the curtain of like
what you're made up of and it's almost
like if you're like traveling through
your own brain you're seeing where
these little behaviors and these beliefs
where they originated and you're like
walking through the old memories of the
memories of the memories and you feel
like you're actually downloading the
things from your your former the
generations before you in your family
ancestry and the trauma that's been
passed down i mean it feels like so
all-encompassing but the thing that
happened like the instant that i entered
the journey was the voice in my head and
some people call it mother ayahuasca
they say it's like you know she's the
thing
i what happened to me was like no no
this is your voice this is your highest
self-voice yeah and she's come into this
journey to tell you oh man i'm gonna get
emotional but it was just like
like
the message was something along the
lines of um
you are
you are your own god you are you are
your own shaman you don't need you don't
need like
you don't need to look externally for
all the answers like you have it within
you it's like it's all there
and everything that you've gone through
it just showed me like how strong i was
and i just felt so much gratitude and i
it was
it was ah yeah i don't know it's so hard
to put it into words it's hard to
translate it but it's hard to translate
but it's just
knowing that everything that we have is
right here and so i guess like it sounds
almost blasphemous so i have to be
careful how i say this
it was a version of it like like god is
in you yeah
you can access that god is everywhere
it's like that's the whole connectedness
thing that i'm like it's so funny
because all these religions are separate
but the same base idea of god is within
all of us
it's like you you hear that message
again through plant therapy through
ayahuasca through
you know whatever trips or whatever it
like it's like the you are all receiving
the same message just have different
faces to the message and and that's why
i ha that's why i choose to believe that
spiritual part well i feel it for one
but also like i think it's the same
thing like calling it god or the
universe or um source or whatever
light
same and it's in all of us and even if
you want to get sciency about it like
we're all made of the same matter like
we're all the entire universe has the
same
matter to it so it's we're all the same
yeah that's right yeah and it's
interesting because you're like well
what does that mean what is that light
or source or god and i think it just
like
it begs a certain thing from all of us
which is
um an adherence and a trust in who we
are
and and living
like every day with authenticity and
vulnerability and with an awareness of
that
and i think where people start to have a
really troubling time on plant medicines
and i will put myself in this category
and the first time that i went in was i
was living in a way the manifestation of
my life was directly in friction
with what i actually felt was right for
me
and so going into a plant medicine
experience where you're just stripping
all of it away
and you're seeing all of these areas in
which you might
not be living your most authentic life
or you might not be like
looking at your pain
then it will show you yeah if you have
if you haven't gone through an ego death
like it's your ego that's wanting to
hold on to this like no no no we're
we're keeping this we built this we
worked really hard for this yeah and i
don't care if it's not the authentic uh
it's this like with this is us baby and
then that status yeah so the money
further you whatever part you are from
that i think that's
the first time you went through it
you were probably experiencing
like what was trying to be an ego death
yeah and then the second time it's like
you already got stripped of everything
your dear ego was killed
she was very gentle she was like
remember this guy she ran all over the
car she's like this look baby i already
put you through enough
she was like look you you listen
good because guess what because if you
didn't this was about to be real bad for
you yeah but it seems like you've got
that nurturing
i i felt like a blanket got put over me
while you were telling your story like
um i was just wondering if you've had
these conversations with other people
that have gone through these experiences
or traumatic events because as you've
been talking i can feel there's a
if you're in the room and you can feel
someone being genuine uh they radiate
and it's and it's different there's a
different type of energy that you're
giving up i could feel it at one point
in my chest i could feel the like pain
and just it feels motivational to fix my
[ __ ]
or to start doing the self work
so that when these days do come that are
hard i can get through it to where it's
like okay
cause she said the first time
because the first time she met
that was the evil step mother
right that wasn't the mom this was the
stepmom like some cinderella [ __ ] and
i'm like i don't want to meet her maybe
i got to do some work before
because she sounds messed up but through
the process i mean
it does feel like
do the work now while we can so that
when those days do come we're able to
reach into whatever it is that we
believe in self
uh the universe god whatever it is your
friends your family so again
this has been an interesting experience
being in the room and to feel it so i
hope that everybody that's watching
right now is able to even get a bit of
what i took away because i don't know i
don't know anything about you i i didn't
know anything yeah we got a three
randomly yeah we're here hi very nice to
meet you for the very first time but it
is an amazing
way that you've told your story
so thank you and i hope that everybody
that's watching is able to take
something away from it because i feel
like this was important absolutely so
much
i'm going to do some kind of man for
sure
girls
oh look at that text message i am not
going to that one
we could stay here in this spot and have
a trip
yeah well i've heard a lot about
ayahuasca i've never experienced it or
or
dmt or anything but uh it sounds like
in a controlled environment with someone
that knows what they're doing barium
killer or therapy with a healer or a
therapist
not on your own no no you could really
traumatize yourself absolutely i've
heard those stories as well so i'm very
i'm always very vocal yes um but yeah i
i feel like maybe we're shifting towards
uh these alternate um alternative
therapies and alternative medicines and
and it's interesting to see where it
goes but um yeah check out taryn on
everything she's always working on
something really [ __ ] cool that will
blow your mind and i don't want to hype
it up too much but like that's every
time i look at her whatever she's
working on it's like okay now she's
working on how ais can make blind people
see again that's
all
[Laughter]
everywhere and is there anything else
that you want anyone to know about or
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much for being appreciated i love you i
mainly just update instagram now i don't
really do any of the other social media
things so if anyone has questions about
plant medicines i'm actually gonna do a
post about plant medicine awesome yeah
this week so well you got us learn a lot
about scenarios you are definitely
interested yes i can feel you
i'm like
no well thank you so much for listening
and leave a comment for taryn and um we
hope that you are
uh feeling very grateful and blessed for
your life and those around you hug
everyone around you and uh we will see
you next time bye
[Music]
foreign